[Musique]
bienvenue dans le débat sur France 24
consacré à la Coupe du Monde au Qatar
avec le tout premier match pour l'équipe
de France face à l'Australie c'est dans
un peu moins d'une heure à 20h heure de
Paris 22 heures à Doha les Bleus sont
arrivés dans la peau des champions du
monde entier 4 ans et demi après leur
victoire en finale de l'édition russe
face à la Croatie un statut flanqué
d'une malédiction la nation tenante du
titre lors de la phase de groupe du
Mondial est éliminée prématurément et ce
depuis l'édition de 2010 alors les Bleus
parviendront-ils à déjouer la
malédiction avec les forfaits de Pogba
Ngolo Kanté et qui PMB et maintenant
Benzema dans quel état d'esprit sont-ils
quelle est l'ambiance dans le stade et
bien on va parler foot ce soir vous avez
compris avec des connaisseurs en plus
j'ai le plaisir d'avoir à mes côtés
Claude Leroy bonsoir ancien footballeur
entraîneur ancien sélectionneur des
équipes africaines du Cameroun du
Sénégal du Ghana et aujourd'hui donc
sélectionné pour la Coupe du monde
d'ailleurs ces équipes merci d'être avec
nous ce soir si le verre henrichissait
bonsoir consultant en sport
international membre du conseil
scientifique sport histoire et
citoyenneté pour Paris 2024 bienvenue à
vous également Jérôme Gessel bonsoir
journaliste sportif et écrivain auteur
de la face cachée du football business
c'est chez Flammarion évidemment d'une
biographie de Platini entre nous coécrit
d'ailleurs avec Platini et ça c'est aux
éditions de l'Observatoire bienvenue à
vous nous avons en direct du stade
agenoube au Qatar ce n'est pas très loin
c'est à 18 km de Doha notre envoyé
spécial Elliott Samuel Eliott bonsoir
bonsoir Stéphanie vous m'entendez bien
alors avant de démarrer cette discussion
on va d'abord écouter Didier Deschamps
c'était il y a quelques jours
tout fait pour que l'ensemble du groupe
soit au mieux pour
ce premier match qui est
très important il n'est pas décisif mais
le premier match de la compétition et
toujours très important donc il y a pas
avoir
d'anxiété ou quoi que ce soit de
calme et sérénité mais avant sachant de
par l'adversaire qu'on aura quel qu'il
soit mais l'Australien fait partie c'est
le très haut niveau donc il faudra tous
les ingrédients nécessaires
Eliott on démarre avec vous puisque vous
êtes sur place sont-ils arrivés dans le
calme et la sérénité
les Bleus ils sont arrivés en tout cas
ici au stade Al Janoub donc au sud de
Doha vous l'avez dit elle est bleue qui
vont bientôt fouler la pelouse pour
l'échauffement d'avant match sérénité en
tout cas on les a vu ces derniers jours
ils avaient l'air plutôt serein plutôt
détendu plutôt complices mais là on
arrive maintenant dans un premier match
de Coupe du Monde beaucoup de joueurs
vont découvrir cette Coupe du Monde a
commencé par la défense évidemment
Ibrahima Konaté et d'ailleurs tout pas
mécano qui vont devoir tenir les rênes
de cette défense française et qui vont
découvrir une coupe du monde dans quel
état d'esprit
seront-ils au moment de foulée la
pelouse au moment d'entendre la
Marseillaise c'est évidemment une des
grandes questions la composition
d'équipe qui en tout cas vient d'être
annoncé par la FIFA pas de surprise par
rapport à ce qui avait été annoncé
depuis plusieurs heures maintenant avec
donc cette défense on l'a dit au pas
mécano Konaté Varane qui est laissé sur
le banc lui qui a repris l'entraînement
collectif seulement samedi dernier le
milieu de terrain avec traumani rabiot
Griezmann juste devant ces deux joueurs
et puis Mbappé à gauche Dembélé à droite
et Giro en pointe les Bleus qui vont
enfin pouvoir commencer la défense de
leur titre dans quelques minutes
maintenant que le roi est-ce qu'il vous
pouvez justement aussi rebondir puisque
maintenant c'est l'annonce officielle si
je comprends bien il y a une inquiétude
autour de la défense avec Konaté ce
qu'ils vont pouvoir déjouer cette
fameuse malédiction des champions du
champion du titre pour espérer moi j'ai
plutôt le sentiment que finalement toute
cette cascade de forfait ça a dû les
libérer complètement psychologiquement
parce qu'ils arrivaient dans la peau
d'un des trois gros favoris avec le
Brésil et l'Argentine et maintenant
qu'on voit toutes ces absences dont le
Ballon d'Or tout le monde se dit à la
France la pauvre France il y a plus
beaucoup de chance fort quand on regarde
les joueurs ils sont du Bayern du Milan
du Real du Paris-Saint-Germain Tottenham
de tous les grands clubs européens il y
a là il y a une équipe plutôt attractive
au départ que Didier a mis en a mis en
place donc avec cette défense justement
qui est un peu d'expérience on dit
oui mais qui a du talent qui a un gros
potentiel athlétique et puis vous savez
il y a 4 ans
Pavard et Hernandez étaient aussi des
nouveaux venus dans le plus haut concert
international et ça avait été des
grosses révélations et c'était aussi de
défenseurs de défenseur extérieur
maintenant on a deux défenseurs centraux
nouveaux mais je crois je crois qu'il y
a vraiment beaucoup de qualités en plus
donc ils ont des automatismes et ça
c'est plutôt un atout pour pour l'équipe
de France de pas avoir une charnière
complètement inédite parce que souvent
les défenseurs centraux enfin je parle
sous le contrôle évidemment de Claude
mais il communique beaucoup et ils
doivent être très complémentaires et ce
sera le cas puisqu'ils ont déjà leur
automatisme qu'ils ont pu avoir à le
pschic mais c'est leur première fois en
Coupe du Monde c'est la première fois en
Coupe du monde ils ont des automatismes
parce qu'ils ont ils ont effectivement
joué ensemble à la M6 à peu près deux
ans ensemble donc ils ont des
automatismes c'est à dire qu'ils ont pas
besoin de se chercher ils vont se
trouver automatiquement sauf que là on
n'est pas en Ligue des Champions on
n'est pas en championnat d'Allemagne
c'est là qu'on est en Coupe du monde
c'est-à-dire qu'on est un niveau dessus
on est un cran au-dessus il y a de
l'émotion qui va énormément émotionnel
émotionnel continuons entendre la
Marseillaise ils se sont préparés alors
la préparation fait très courte quand
même mais dans leur tête qui se réparent
quand même depuis quelques semaines à ce
moment-là la montée la Marseillaise la
pression plus l'Australie qu'il faut pas
oublier qui eux jouent contre les
champions du monde entier c'est-à-dire
que ils vont tout mettre dans dans cette
rencontre pour pouvoir défier la France
ça peut jouer ça peut peut-être faire
les jouets parce que gros problème des
Français c'est toujours un problème de
concentration il y a 4 ans on avait eu
beaucoup de mal contre l'Australie alors
là c'est une petite ironie de l'histoire
parce qu'on retrouve le même adversaire
qu'en 2018 bon ça nous avait porté
beaucoup de chance à la fin mais c'est
vrai qu'on avait il y a 4 ans en 2018 en
Russie on avait remporté le match de bu
à 1 mais ça avait été très serré avec un
match nul enfin les Australiens
légalisés ça avait été un but un petit
peu gag de Pogba qui avait offert la
victoire l'équipe de France donc
ce soir ce même type de match très serré
il y a une petite question qui se pose
c'est au niveau mental c'est ou pas
mécano qui fait des matchs remarquables
avec le Bayern il faut quand même
rappeler que trois des quatre défenseurs
sont des défenseurs du Bayern qui est
peut-être aujourd'hui la meilleure
équipe en Europe donc c'est quand même
un gage de grande qualité et de qualité
malgré la nouveauté donc oui par contre
ou pas mécano pour le moment n'a pas
encore réussi avec l'équipe de France
autant il fait des matchs remarquables
avec le Bayern autant pour le moment il
a un petit peu de mal justement dans cet
aspect psychologique dans cette petite
montée d'escalier qui fait la différence
entre un club et l'équipe nationale
c'est plus le l'hymne de la Champions
League c'est la Marseillaise et ça ça
peut intervenir mais moi je voulais dire
quelque chose c'est que depuis plusieurs
jours je suis tout est conférences de
presse et je suis très étonné de la
qualité intellectuelle de tous ces
jeunes joueurs dans toutes leurs
interventions dans toutes leurs
interviews ils montrent une maturité
assez incroyable et moi je je suis je
suis vraiment scotché de devant cette
jeune génération qui me semble être un
pas en avant par rapport à la dernière
Elliott vous qui êtes sur place parce
que évidemment on s'attend effectivement
à une pression émotionnelle plus forte
sur cette jeune génération qui joue ce
soir
en tout cas ils n'ont pas montré qu'ils
étaient sous pression qui craignaient
évidemment d'entrer en Coupe du Monde
vous en parler en Platon on a vu des
jeunes joueurs effectivement conférence
de presse on y était en a vu des Axel
Xavi des Yusuf Fofana être plutôt serein
et même après la blessure et le forfait
de Karim Benzema alors dans la foulée
évidemment on a vu des mines défaites à
la sortie de l'entraînement mais dès le
lendemain on y était à cet entraînement
les Bleus paraissaient détendus
paraissaient complices paraissait serein
malgré le choc du forfait du Ballon d'Or
donc on a eu ce sentiment d'une équipe
de France plutôt en confiance maintenant
avoir évidemment quand on approche à
quelques heures d'un tel rendez-vous
d'une telle entrée en Coupe du Monde il
faut voir dans quel état d'esprit les
joueurs seront mais en tout cas ces
derniers jours ils avaient l'air assez
confiants
c'est vrai que c'est un gros manque hein
c'est le Ballon d'Or donc le meilleur
joueur du monde mais paradoxalement ça
peut aussi libérer qu'il y a une BAP
alors on sait que il a besoin d'être
libéré il aime bien jouer en fait un peu
technique mais il aime bien jouer avec
un vrai avant-centre c'est-à-dire un
pivot qui vit jouer en remise qui dévie
des ballons de la tête et il y a
quelques semaines il avait dit lors d'un
interview avec le club du Paris
Saint-Germain qu'il était beaucoup plus
libre en équipe de France avec un joueur
comme Giroud avant centre que au Paris
Saint-Germain où il avait davantage de
tâches défensives à accomplir donc là il
va pouvoir on l'attend au tournant là il
va être à mon avis le facteur X de
l'équipe de France tout le monde va
jouer pour lui et donc ça peut être
aussi un atout
majeurs il aime bien se transformer en
dépositaire de l'aventure donc c'est
vrai que je pense que ce rôle là lui
convient parfaitement du Sauveur il
avait quasiment été il y a 4 ans très
jeune à 19 ans vous parlez de sauveur
déjà en parlant de papier pour ce soir
oui non mais c'était déjà le cas il y a
4 ans sur les moments importants dans
cette Coupe du Monde il avait été
présent et puis à nouveau aujourd'hui il
se retrouve
ce dont il faut se méfier ce soir c'est
de l'impact athlétique de cette équipe
australienne parce que pour les avoir
joué souvent dans ma carrière comme
sélectionneur c'est vrai que
il ne rechigne pas au combat oui non non
c'est une équipe alors
rustique j'allais dire ça en
paraphrasant Audiard non non mais c'est
une équipe c'est une équipe physique
d'ailleurs ça correspond à leur sport en
général vous prenez tous les sports
collectifs des Australiens ils sont très
physiques ils jouent sur le physique ils
appuient c'est le sport de l'hémisphère
sud on parle de Mbappé mais je pense
qu'il faut parler aussi de toute
l'attaque qui est très intéressante
puisque on agit et Griezmann ce qui est
intéressant avec Jérôme Griezmann c'est
qu'on a deux joueurs qui aiment bien
jouer l'un avec l'autre et on a
Griezmann qui aime bien avoir on peut le
dire parce qu'il me semble qu'à une
époque à une époque c'était peut-être un
mais là
très amis très amis mais par contre vous
avez raison c'est que Mbappé Géraud un
moment il y a eu un petit peu de friture
entre batte et Giroud mais je parle de
Griezmann
il y a vraiment il y a quelque chose qui
fonctionne très bien il y a une vraie
complicité et je crois que ça va être
intéressant de les voir fonctionner
surtout avec un Giroud qui n'hésite pas
justement à tout de suite être dans le
défensif dès que l'équipe a besoin de
lui donc il n'hésitera pas à revenir et
c'est un jour aussi qui sur le plan
athlétique Giroud qui sont sur le plan
physique s'impose et dans ce combat
parce que mettre un combat contre les
Australiens je pense ce soir on aura
besoin d'un Giroud parce que ma seule
réserve c'est sur son âge puisque Giroud
a 36 ans et c'est de me dire comment il
va pouvoir enchaîner aussi des matchs
tous les trois jours avec intensité
est-ce qu'il va pouvoir jouer tous les
matchs alors on parle des trop jeune et
puis il est trop vieux donc voilà
occupons-nous du premier oui déjà oui il
sera 7 ans en plus à 36 ans 37 ans étant
à penalty aujourd'hui magnifique les
vieux ils savent faire
du coup là tout le monde
Griezmann en tout cas il va disputer lui
sa troisième Coupe du monde donc ça fait
quand même là pour le coup c'est un
joueur à guéri un cadre oui il va
pouvoir apporter son expérience alors
c'est vrai que on parlait des vieux et
des des jeunes ce qui est bien dans une
équipe aussi c'est d'avoir ce mélange
entre les plus anciens et les qui
transmettent leur expérience et par
exemple l'équipe du Brésil a fait ça
fait appel à des anciens qui sont
peut-être pas titulaires comme des nids
Alves mais c'est pour transmettre un
petit peu le vécu au plus jeune joueur
et justement qui soit moins inhibé sur
le terrain très très ancien avec Daniel
Griezmann il est en train de faire une
performance d'accomplir une performance
incroyable je crois que ce soit c'est
son 68e match consécutif sans
interruption en démarrant un match avec
l'équipe nationale ce qui n'est jamais
arrivé
Elliot est une réaction justement sur
cette équipe d'attaquant
Antoine Griezmann on en a peut-être pas
assez parlé mais peut-être en l'absence
de Karim Benzema oui Mbappé va être
libéré mais aussi et sans doute
Griezmann on se souvient qu'à l'horiz
marchait vraiment un peu dessus
Griezmann avait vraiment beaucoup de mal
à trouver sa place là il va retrouver un
poste qui l'affectionne alors on va lui
demander d'avoir ce poste un peu hybride
sans doute ce soir et de descendre en
milieu relayeur mais il a ce poste au
milieu de terrain qui qu'il affectionne
et puis dans l'attaque il y a un autre
peut-être qu'il faut qu'on mentionne
c'est Dembélé c'est ça revanche à
prendre il y a 4 ans il était aussi
titulaire face à l'Australie il avait
complètement raté son match donc
aujourd'hui pour lui c'est l'heure de la
revanche Dembélé qui sera scruté de près
s'il veut avoir sa chance pour la suite
de la compétition car il y a quatre ans
après France Australie on l'avait à
peine revue c'est un funambule il faut
pas qu'il tombe du fil quoi faut pas
qu'il tombe du fil c'est comme tous les
artistes
ça se joue très très peu de choses lui
c'est ce dont je parlais hier c'est
Mohamed Bougard ça qui dit la vie c'est
une ligne de crête entre deux précipices
il est toujours sur cette ligne de Crète
exactement et il faut il faut qu'il soit
attention mais c'est un joueur
exceptionnellement doué quoi d'accord
c'est la métaphore du funambule est tout
à fait vrai et moi il me fait penser
alors j'étais pas né mais un peu dans le
profil et de ce côté funambuliste
justement à Gary chat dribbleur un
joueur vraiment atypique non mais il
faut le laisser il faut le laisser
évoluer à la limite c'est presque un
joueur qu'il faut pas donner de consigne
il faut le laisser il faut le laisser
faire un inspiration et quand il est en
Sylla son inspiration alors ça donne des
choses comme le dit Claude exceptionnel
donc si les trois là devant sont
justement dans un dans une belle soirée
dans un montant dans un bon tempo et
s'ils arrivent à se trouver à coulisser
ça peut donner des choses en attaque
fantastique ils sont des combattants ce
soir que de Laura votre avis là ils ont
ce côté guerrier oui parce justement on
parle de Giroud Giroud va jouer un rôle
très important dans la récupération
collective et surtout les coups de pied
défensifs aériens parce que sa taille
son jeu de tête c'est quelquefois
quelque chose qui nous manque sur notre
jeu défensif et lui quand il revient il
soulage beaucoup tous les défenseurs
derrière on a deux athlètes incroyables
avec ou pas mécano et Konaté donc avec
deux joueurs sur le côté qui s'y même
s'ils sont un petit peu moins
dragster qu'il y a 4 ans
ont emmagasiné de la maturité tactique
et vont et devrait être très présents
donc moi je crois cette équipe me plaît
bien à priori mais ça c'est ce qu'on dit
toujours avant les matchs
je pense que le sportif français toute
discipline confondue n'est pas le
meilleur quand il est dans le confort on
ne peut pas dire qu'on soit réellement
dans le confort
c'est bien d'avoir de la diversité et
c'est vrai de pas répondre
de favoris on a vu par exemple tout à
l'heure l'Argentine qui était avant ce
papier quasiment parmi
l'Argentine qui a été battu par l'Arabie
l'Arabie Saoudite et ben c'est déjà un
signal fort d'envoyer pour cette coupe
du monde et se dire les matchs il faut
les gagner et c'est pas parce qu'on est
meilleurs sur le papier que
automatiquement on empêche la victoire
parce que tout de même survendu l'argent
le match donc l'Arabie Saoudite qui a
gagné contre l'Argentine on les a
survendu moi hier j'étais dans une autre
émission
je disais que je voyais pas du tout
l'Argentine à l'arrivée loin sans faut
comme l'Espagne parce que je pense
qu'ils ont un joueur qui est un soleil
qui m'a un peu de lumière sur tous les
autres mais il y a que des joueurs de
complément il y a pas de grand joueur à
côté des dans cette équipe et dès qu'il
est un petit peu inhibé Messi il apporte
pas grand chose et je savais qu'avec
Hervé Renard à la tête de l'équipe
d'Arabie Saoudite pour l'avoir quasiment
tous les jours tous les deux jours au
téléphone il avait bien préparé son
affaire il avait bossé comme des fois en
Espagne ça fait deux mois que tous ces
joueurs sont ensemble contrairement dans
Paris Sylvia thaler ou les joueurs sont
arrivés là pour les grandes équipes où
il y a que des pros au dernier moment et
tactiquement on a vu une équipe
incroyablement prête qu'a poser des
problèmes en jouant très haut une ligne
de hors-jeu à 45 m de ses buts en
prenant tous les risques mais les
risques payants donc chapeau au saoudien
puis chapeau à notre campagne parce
qu'en fait il y a quelques jours de cela
j'ai lu un petit entrefilé ou Claude
disait dans la presse il faut surveiller
cette équipe alors qu'est-ce que je fais
je suis allé sur les réseaux sociaux
parce que moi je connaissais pas le jeu
de de cette équipe je suis allé sur les
réseaux sociaux pour voir un peu ça a
été un peu difficile de trouver des
images hein mais j'ai trouvé quelques
images et j'ai vu je me suis rendu
compte qu'effectivement ils étaient en
place que c'est une équipe qui
physiquement tactiquement été comme vous
l'avez dit en place notamment avec des
blogs qui coulissaient très très bien et
moi ce que j'ai aimé c'est quand en
deuxième période ils ont pas bloqué le
jeu parce qu'ils auraient pu se dire bon
ça y est on perd un zéro face Argentine
on va assurer non ils ont quand même
décidé d'aller de l'orgueil de pousser
de pousser vraiment vers l'avant et ça
c'était vraiment très très intéressant
donc chapeau à cette équipe
ils ont livré un très grand match
aujourd'hui absolument des sont attirés
pour les Bleus ça veut dire qu'il y a
pas de petites équipes en Coupe du monde
et qu'il faut se méfier de évidemment de
tout le monde non vous savez tout le
monde depuis hier disait l'Arabie
Saoudite ça va être comme le Qatar les
gens qui connaissent tout au foot qui
qui portent déjà des jugements
définitifs alors qu'on est au deuxième
jour de compétition non il y a des
grandes différences entre les équipes le
Qatar vaut beaucoup mieux que ce qu'ils
ont montré au match d'ouverture ou les
chairs et les émirs ayant du multiplier
les visites dans les vestiaires les ont
tétanisé les ont complètement inhibé en
disant vous avez la responsabilité de
l'honneur de tout un pays et je pense
qu'ils les ont vous y est la
psychologiquement on va voir qu'après
ils sont quand même meilleur que ce
qu'ils ont montré mais l'Arabie Saoudite
c'est un très grand pays de football
c'est un pays où moi aussi j'ai joué
souvent joué il y a 40 ou 45000
personnes pour les matchs de championnat
c'est véritablement
c'est une grande nationalité attention
la suffisance parce que là les argentés
ont été suffisants le Brésil est en
train d'être suffisant parce que ça y
est Neymar a collé une sixième étoile
sur son short et il commence à dire ça y
est on a préparé des danses une dizaine
de danse pour célébrer les buts
attention la suffisance il faut que
l'équipe de France aujourd'hui soit
concentré l'Australie et techniquement
et moins bonne mais il faut qu'il soit
concentré qui fasse le match parce que
si ils sont pas concentrés qui sont
suffisant il risque d'avoir des
changements de relise le bûcher des
vanités exactement exactement
Elliott vous qui êtes sur place il faut
relire le bûcher des vanités en tout cas
les Bleus l'ont peut-être lu avant ce
match
ouais c'est une piqûre de rappel en tout
cas ce match de l'Argentine tout à
l'heure mais je pense pas que les Bleus
vont prendre cette équipe d'Australie de
eux pour plusieurs raisons tout d'abord
il y a 4 ans ils ont affronté cette
équipe d'Australie il se souviennent de
comment s'est passé ce match que ils
s'en sont sortis à la toute dernière
seconde enfin dans les 10 dernières
minutes en tout cas de très peu et puis
la leçon de l'euro de l'année dernière
les Bleus sont arrivés assez confiants
et le rôle en passé ils vont pas
reproduire je pense les mêmes erreurs en
tout cas on espère pas l'année dernière
et il menait trois à quelques minutes de
la fin contre la Suisse la qualification
pour les quarts de finale était assuré
je pense que la leçon était retenue et
puis il y a cette cascade de péripéties
de forfait qui a enchaîné cette piqûre
de rappel pour les Bleus donc
normalement avec tous ces enchaînements
il ne devrait pas prendre cette équipe
d'Australie de haut en tout cas ce sera
surveiller dans quelques minutes en tout
cas le temps de préparation était
particulièrement court il a fallu
s'adapter c'est compliqué pour une
équipe oui c'est difficile pour avoir
préparer beaucoup de grandes
compétitions des coupes du monde des
Coupes d'Afrique ou des coupes d'Asie
c'est vrai que quand on a qu'une semaine
pour faire venir tous ces joueurs en
plus en ne connaissant pas exactement
dans quel état physique ils arrivent
parce que c'est assez disparate on se
connaît pas en plus les modes de
préparation qui a eu dans les différents
clubs donc c'est difficile mais on a la
chance alors quand j'entends qu'il est
vipendait critiqué avant même que comme
il était en 2018 comme il est en 2014
Didier Deschamps qui pour moi est le
meilleur entraîneur français de tous les
temps ne sont pas le Marais se plait
pour lui je comprends pas bien et lui il
aura comme le disait notre parmi à Doha
il aura eu le temps de mettre tout le
monde en garde et de se de bien leur
répéter que l'Australie ça va pas être
une partie de plaisir qui va falloir
véritablement être prêt mentalement à un
combat difficile au niveau athlétique et
à partir de là on fera la différence
techniquement mais il faut déjà être au
même niveau que au niveau athlétique
préparation très courte donc ça c'est
très inédit il faut le rappeler oui donc
il y a des joueurs qui sont arrivés
blessés on pense à Benzema qui est
arrivé blessé alors moi la seule
beaucoup de blessés alors moi la seule
réserve que j'ai en fait Didier
Deschamps a renoncé à prendre à 26e
joueur là j'aimerais bien avoir la vidéo
25 il aurait pu prendre un 26e j'aurais
bien aimé qu'il prenne Martin Terrier
alors il a expliqué que peut-être pour
l'équilibre du groupe c'était c'était
compliqué mais je pense que d'offrir une
coupe du monde à un joueur comme on
avait la possibilité de prendre un
joueur en plus voilà ça c'est un choix
que j'ai franchement j'ai pas trop
compris il y avait 66 sélectionneurs
d'ailleurs avec le forfait de Benzema
chacun voulait avoir son joueur mais on
sera préparation qui était courte moi je
trouve que c'est très bien parce que ça
évite cette période très très longue où
l'équipe est sous le feu de la presse on
se souvient de 98 ce que Aimé Jacquet a
pris dans la figure juste avant de
rentrer dans la compétition finalement
c'est pas si mal parce que
ils se font pas si critiquer que ça il y
a eu en plus l'épisode Benzema qui est
détourne un peu l'attention donc c'est
les amis un peu surtout avec les réseaux
sociaux aujourd'hui qui sont très actifs
et qui peuvent avoir une insuffisance
aussi sur le moral des joueurs donc je
trouve que c'est c'est je trouve que
c'est très très bien je pense qu'il a
voulu stabiliser son en appelant pas en
joueur en même temps les critiques de la
presse en 98 non pas porter préjudice
avec l'équipe de France puisqu'elle a
été championne du monde à pesto royale
sur l'instant je peux vous dire que ça a
été un enfer pour aimer Jacquet
jusqu'à aujourd'hui il le vit très très
mal il vit très très mal oui parce que
là c'était un nominéenne c'était
vraiment complètement qui coûte touchait
l'homme et là ça l'est au-delà de la
simple critique pour parler du joueur
pour répondre oui je crois qu'il a voulu
stabiliser son groupe et puis quand vous
installez vous êtes sélectionneur sont
des joueurs professionnels leurs
fonctions c'est de jouer quand vous en
avez 25 vous savez quand vous faites
votre équipe il y a 14 déçu quand vous
en avez 26 il y en a 15 mois vous avez
déçu mais vous vous portez moi c'est pas
mal Elliott moi vous êtes déçu mais vous
portez donc 25 joueurs au lieu de 26 ça
faisait partie de la sélection oui mais
qui a des pieds sur terre qui qui posent
les vraies questions moi j'ai regretté
que on n'avait pas un peu plus loin sur
ce sur ce bandeau LGBT qu'on soit pas un
petit peu plus courageux dans cette
affaire là parce que je pense que la
FIFA aurait été quand même mis en péril
c'est intéressant vous y reveniez parce
qu'effectivement et bien ils ont dû y
renoncer y compris toutes les autres
équipes qui les équipes européennes qui
voulaient d'ailleurs le porter
la FIFA l'a interdit en tout cas ça
c'était la dernière décision de FIFA
très bien alors que si les 32 équipes
avaient décidé comme un seul homme de
porter ce brassard personne n'aurait
discuté la FIFA
fait pas le figure elle aurait pu penser
que les sportifs auraient dû s'engager
je pense et dire à la FIFA un docteur un
architecte un ouvrier un remouleur il
peut être il peut avoir aussi des idées
politiques on a l'impression que les
footballeurs professionnels vous les
entraîneurs sont coupés de ce mandat
n'ont pas du tout on est des gens comme
tout le monde et on a aussi le droit de
défendre des causes c'est intéressant
Jérôme qu'on a pu se rendre compte de la
duplicité de Gianni afin qui à la fois
dans un double discours dit qui se sent
gay mais qui dans notre côté interdit le
brassard
multicolore du
Qatar ça c'est l'argument d'ailleurs
c'est tellement facile en fait de se
coucher comme ça mais il en a l'habitude
de toute façon donc on est même pas
surpris mais c'est vrai que il manque à
la tête du football un homme fort et on
va très bien d'ailleurs déjà dès le
départ un peu les petites dérives qui
qui peut exister par exemple là il a dit
parce que il n'a jamais été footballeur
donc il dit il faut absolument
un footballeur footballeur il avait les
maillots à l'époque et en fait là il y a
des arrêts de jeu de 14 minutes parce
qu'il voudrait monsieur Infantino qui
est 45 minutes de temps de jeu
effectivement le responsable
il est pas autonome dans ces décisions
si vous connaissez un petit peu le
fonctionnement il faut avoir en fait il
faut penser à la démarche politique
d'infanterie se pro déjà sur la
prochaine assemblée générale de la
facture aura lieu à Kigali en mars
prochain et lors de cette assemblée
qu'est-ce qu'il veut il va absolument
avoir déjà les voix de l'Afrique il va
avoir les voix de certains pays pour qui
ce problème et je prends pas parti je
constate pour qui ce problème de ce
problème justement de de de des couleurs
LGBT pose problème donc il a une
démarche purement politique et c'est des
messages qui fait passer à travers ce
discours une démarche politique contre
une autre démarche politique
quand on est dans la rue exactement
c'est paradoxal
déjà la femme devait être contente parce
que elle qui me reproche toujours d'en
mettre plein la tête à une Fantino pour
une fois j'avais pas parlé d'une
revient on revient sur Infantino pour
moi il est il est pathétique parce qu'il
parle à l'Afrique justement 54 pays
africains ils parlent jamais de foot il
ne parle que de fric exactement ah il a
une démarche de chef d'entreprise il le
reconnaît il affirme c'est vrai qu'on
est loin du rectangle vert il habite à
Doha ça c'est un peu ça pose un problème
ça effectivement en tout cas difficile
de parler de sport sans parler de
politique puisqu'on a vu que l'équipe
des Iraniens les Iraniens avant
justement du match ont refusé de chanter
l'hymne national si c'est pas un geste
politique
le plus fort depuis le début de cette
Coupe du Monde ah franchement j'ai dit
chapeau des Iraniens donc des hommes qui
défendent la cause des femmes ça sert
aussi à ça
c'est aussi ça la force du football le
football universel et là tout le monde a
repris effectivement élargissons s'il
vous plaît parce qu'il n'y a pas que les
footballeurs en ce qui concerne il faut
parler aussi des des joueurs de
water-polo il faut parler des
basketteuses qui ont fait oui mais
il faut les artistes il faut parler de
tous les sportifs qui ont qui ont fait
cet acte de bravo et c'est même plus
dangereux pour ses athlètes qui sont
moins connues que les footballeurs parce
qu'ils sont pas protégés par la
popularité c'est pour ça qu'il faut
élargir les footballeurs ils sont encore
un tout petit peu protégés
on parle de 5 milliards de personnes qui
vont mais je parle de la mise en danger
c'est à dire que si demain les
basketteuses disparaissent et sont
torturés personne n'en parlera alors
qu'un jour de foot si lui il met en
prison si effectivement sur l'audience
quand on parle le courage et parle aussi
de tous les sports on a vu avec des gens
aussi très célèbres en Iran ou
d'émetteurs en scène ou des réalisateurs
ou des comédiennes qu'ils étaient prêts
à tout quel que soit la renommée de
tous les jours mais
ils doivent s'engager quand même c'est
football voleur mais bien sûr on doit
toujours s'engager moi j'ai passé ma vie
à m'engager politiquement pendant toute
ma carrière et de footballeur et
d'entraîneur alors ça m'a valu de
prendre des bons coups de bâton mais je
ne regrette pas une seconde si le
footballeur est un monde très
conservateur et très consensuel ou en
fait on fait les petits coups par
derrière mais c'est vrai que quand on
défend ses idées on défend ses
convictions et ben c'est vrai qu'on est
pas toujours le bienvenu Eliot Samuel
effectivement il y a eu le fait que
cette équipe d'iranien a pas chanté
l'hymne national iranien avant justement
le match et ça ça a marqué c'est ses
premiers jours de la Coupe du monde
oui bien sûr ça a été un des moments
forts de ce Mondial si on en a beaucoup
parlé ici à Doha c'était l'un des
premiers actes forts en réalité et c'est
parce que la FIFA on a vu que la FIFA
réussit à de très nombreux moyens
bloquer les équipes on a parlé du
brassard LGBT et ils ont tout tenté au
début c'était financièrement seulement
et toutes les équipes qui souhaitaient
le faire et ça a pas été le cas de la
France de manière assez surprenante les
équipes qui avaient dit même si on a une
amende on portera ce brassard ils
allaient le faire la FIFA elle a réussi
à trouver le moyen c'était en mettant
une sanction sportive à savoir des
cartons jaunes aux joueurs qui portaient
le brassard et là évidemment ça change
tout parce que les sélections ne veulent
pas perdre un joueur sur un carton rouge
bêtement pris donc là c'était le premier
acte fort qui a fait beaucoup parler qui
a réjoui beaucoup de gens qu'on puisse
quand même contourner certaines règles
de la FIFA campus encore s'exprimer sur
un terrain de foot l'objectif du
président de la FFR il me semble c'est
l'arrivée en demi-finale finalement
c'est quoi c'est l'avenir de Deschamps
qui se joue là c'est ce qu'il a dit il a
dit que à partir du l'équipe arrivait en
demi-finale c'est Didier qui déciderait
si oui ou non il continue son aventure à
la tête de l'équipe de France je pense
que c'est un objectif qui me paraît
abordable malgré les
départs et malgré les blessés mais
après quelle sera l'avenir aussi Noël le
grec
après la Coupe du Monde il s'est
enduites aussi après la plus belle porte
de sortie pour Didier Deschamps ça
serait de remporter cette Coupe du monde
et de partir et c'est ce qui ferait
voilà je pense
est-ce qu'on peut pas faire mieux bon il
a pas gagné l'Euro avec l'équipe de
l'équipe de France en tout cas en tant
que sélectionneur mais là il aurait
accompli un
magnifique et s'ils arrivent en
demi-finale
seulement c'est le début d'une bonne
performance allez ils sont contenterait
pas
les demi-finales maintenant bon on est
un peu plus
tout dépend de la manière tout dépend de
la manière de ce que cette équipe va
nous donner du jeu qui va nous proposer
la manière dont on nous on sera derrière
nos télévisions et l'encourager s'ils
sont les émotions que ça qui vont créer
ce qu'on va vivre c'est de la manière
qui va qui sera importante même si il
s'arrête en 8e même s'arrête en car il
nous donne de l'émotion et bien ça c'est
important vous savez pourquoi pour les
jeunes pour les amateurs pour le
football amateur c'est ça qui est
important aussi d'ailleurs que la Coupe
du monde elle a une incidence et la
l'importance capitale pour tous les
autres football parce qu'on parle des
pros là on parle des des 0,2% qui sont
au-dessus de la crème mais le football
ce sont des millions des millions de
joueurs qui jouent alors même il y a du
football en marchant j'ai découvert ça
il y a très peu de temps donc c'est pour
aussi bien pour les vieux le football
marchant que pour les vieux pour tous
ces joueurs là c'est extrêmement
important ça intervient dans des séances
d'entraînement des séances
d'entraînement en marchant pour
justement développer le sens tactique
chez les joueurs moi ça m'arrive de
tester
alors justement en parlant de l'audience
Claude Laura est-ce que vous savez si
finalement cette coupe est aussi suivie
cette coupe du monde que la précédente
avec toutes les controverses qu'il peut
y avoir autour du Qatar malgré les
esprits chagrins moi je vois autour de
moi enfin je vois très peu de gens qui
disent finalement certains disaient non
j'ai pas la regarder puis je leur
demande alors il me dit oui mais le
match d'ouverture
de 2018 ah oui donc finalement toutes
ces controverses autour du Qatar
c'est des fantasmes souvenez-vous on a
participé à une émission justement sur
faut-il boycotter le Qatar c'était il y
a deux semaines et en fait il y avait
beaucoup de fantasmes même sur la
température qu'il allait faire il y
avait pas que des fantasmes
alors certains contenteurs
ou 5 à 40 degrés il fait 24 degrés voilà
voilà elle peut de Leroy vous devez nous
quitter à 45 c'est ce qu'on m'a dit donc
c'est une petite minute bon et ils vont
y arriver là ils vont déjouer cette
malédiction ou pas en amour j'aimerais
bien que ce soir justement par les cils
tout à l'heure c'est que ils montent
qu'on se régale parce que il y a quand
même quatre joueurs offensifs très
complémentaires 1 qui est pas le plus
talentueux mais quand même très présent
par cette par sa puissance athlétique et
sur les côtés qu'il y a et Dembélé
derrière Griezmann qui sont trois
joueurs très très doué c'est fort plus
choix Betty qui est capable de passer
les lignes qui est un joueur si jamais
il se libère complètement qui peut
étonner pendant cette coupe du monde ça
peut être une des grandes révélations de
de la Coupe du monde donc moi je
j'aimerais ce soir qu'on c'est pas le
problème de gagner j'espère qu'on va
gagner bien sûr mais j'aimerais qu'en
plus on montre quelque chose on laisse
partir merci beaucoup d'avoir participé
à cette émission et on va en profiter
pour retrouver à Paris Nina Masson qui
est avec des fans dans un bar à Paris
Nina
oui bonjour à vous Stéphanie et vous le
voyez ici malgré le froid et bien les
Français se sont donnés rendez-vous la
Coupe du monde de football se sont aussi
des bons moments donc ça y est l'équipe
de France ouvre bien une page blanche de
son histoire et lance officiellement
groupe du monde au Qatar ce soir elle la
lance aussi avec ses supporters à Paris
1er match pour les tenants du titre face
à l'Australie et vous le voyez ici le
monde rassemblé dans cette brasserie du
centre de Paris ici les supporters qui
suivent évidemment ce match extrêmement
attendu sur grand écran et tout le monde
sent bien ici que c'est aussi lors de
vérité pour les Bleus qui doivent se
rassurer après avoir perdu beaucoup de
leurs joueurs clés ces dernières
semaines dont le plus connu le Ballon
d'Or bien sûr Karim Benzema qui a
déclaré forfait ce week-end autre grand
absent Ngolo Kanté et Paul Pogba alors
forcément les Bleus mise beaucoup sur
leur
Kylian Mbappe une coupe du monde assez
atypique pour les Bleus on l'a dit mais
aussi pour les français puisqu'il s'agit
c'est à cela peut paraître anecdotique
mais il faut le préciser c'est le
premier mondial qui a lieu en automne
mais malgré le froid vous le voyez les
supporters sont là comme Yves qui est
avec nous bonjour à vous Yves alors
pourquoi vous avez choisi de faire le
déplacement ce soir il fait froid mais
on est venu quand même parce qu'on est
venu soutenir l'équipe de France on est
venu pour la Coupe du Monde moi je suis
pas un fan de foot mais j'adore la Coupe
du Monde on oublie tout le froid les
polémiques bien sûr et Dieu sait si il
fait froid ici
et vous et vous Xavier les polémiques
elles sont derrière vous ce soir à quoi
vous pensez
la terrasse est pas chauffée donc on a
pas trop de scrupules et on est là pour
passer un bon moment entre amis en
famille voilà
on a décidé d'oublier les polémiques
pour les
merci pour
les beaucoup plus de questions que
d'habitude donc en raison des polémique
qui entoure le pays haut de cette inédit
on nous l'a dit aussi dans les rues de
Paris beaucoup de Français ont décidé de
boycotter cette coupe du monde et de ne
voir aucun match mais on le voit ici
dans ce bar parisien et bien la Coupe du
monde semble pour le moment bel et bien
résisté au polémique merci beaucoup Nina
Masson donc à nous envoyer spécial dans
ce fameux bar restaurant parisien silver
donc on parlait justement de cette
audience finalement il y a peu de peu de
gens boycott et puis finalement même
ceux qui ne s'intéressent pas au
football tous les jours ils regardent la
Coupe du Monde c'est ce que vient de
dire Nina j'ai les mêmes à la maison on
regarde il regarde la Coupe du Monde
on pourra pas se rendre compte
puisqu'ils seront dans l'intimité de
leur appartement et on se rend compte
que pour l'instant ça n'a pas
d'incidence et je crois que bon il
faudra continuer à s'intéresser
effectivement conditions de des
travailleurs durant la préparation de
cette Coupe du Monde au nombre de morts
à tous les sujets qu'on qu'on a abordé
ces derniers temps
mais je crois que là on a besoin en ce
moment là de faire un petit stop parce
que on est dans une crise économique qui
est très dure on a une guerre qui est à
1000 km de Paris nous avons des
conditions qui sont vraiment très
difficile et là je crois que les
Français ils veulent attraper un petit
moment qui va leur donner vous savez la
petite fenêtre le rayon d'espoir le
soleil que l'on peut observer et c'est
le football qui peut la porter alors
certains vont dire oui mais il se passe
d'autre chose à côté certes mais pendant
90 minutes pendant l'équipe de France
joue et ils ont ceci profitons de ceci
ça nous empêche pas ensuite par la suite
de réfléchir à toutes ces polémiques à
problématiques dont vous avez parlé ici
bien sûr c'est que après la Coupe du
Monde et bien on en parle plus hein ça
ça reste toujours un risque oui non mais
Jérôme évidemment mais c'est vrai que
comme le dit silver si on peut avoir un
petit coin de ciel bleu dans tous les
sens de terme et puis que les Bleus
aille loin parce que c'est vrai que de
façon un peu mécanique ça augmente un
petit peu le moral on est au mois de
novembre il fait froid ça peut être pour
nous quelque chose un petit un petit
biscuit comme ça sympa et ça nous permet
aussi de mettre entre parenthèse le
climat anxiogène c'est vrai dans lequel
on est baigné en permanence
Elliott je sais que vous devez partir
bientôt justement pour aller dans le
stade lui-même Elliot Samuel Eliott
ouais chanceux comme ils disent ici quel
est l'ambiance
qui est montée évidemment on a vu enfin
les supporters français arrivés ici à
Doha depuis notre arrivée ça avait été
très compliqué de voir des drapeaux bleu
blanc rouge ils seront 3300 supporters
français durant ce match à soutenir les
Bleus 3300 supporters une grande partie
qui vient évidemment de France qui ont
fait le déplacement certains supporters
qui vivent ici à Doha des expatriés ou
d'autres dans les pays voisins mais
voilà l'ambiance derrière les bleus et
enfin monté et maintenant le match va
pouvoir commencer dans quelques petites
minutes et ils espèrent tous ils
attendent tous cette première victoire
des Bleus qui les placerait en tête de
ce groupe D bien sûr on vous retrouvera
après le match
Elliott on vous laisse allez vous
diriger vers le stade je suis désolé de
vous reposer cette question Jérôme mais
forcément j'ai envie de la reposer
est-ce qu'ils vont déjouer cette fameuse
c'est malédiction parce qu'on n'a pas eu
qu'une finalement entre les forfaits
alors c'est vrai que vous titrez la
malédiction des Bleus non mais non il
faut avoir un il faut être un peu
optimiste non je pense ils sont capables
de récidiver leur exploit de 2018 de
faire comme le Brésil en 58 et en 62 de
gagner deux fois de suite on a une
formidable équipe on a un formidable
réservoir il faut savoir que c'est la
grande force aussi de la France c'est
d'avoir beaucoup licencié et d'avoir un
réservoir de talent quasiment
inextinguible donc franchement je pense
que tous les les feux sont au vert en
dépit des blessures et petit signe il y
a eu cet après-midi un match qui qui
sera qui seront les adversaires de la
France c'est-à-dire entre le Danemark et
la Tunisie il y a eu un match nul c'est
déjà un résultat qui favorise déjà les
Français parce que pourquoi parce que si
on gagne on sera comme l'a dit mon
confrère seul en tête et c'est bien que
les adversaires en fait quand ils jouent
entre eux se neutralise c'est le
meilleur des scénario
football entre le Danemark et la Pologne
vous savez moi j'ai pas l'habitude de
dire
Tunisie mais j'ai pour habitude de dire
que les statistiques ce qui concerne que
le passé donc
on aime bien s'appuyer sur et je crois
d'ailleurs même c'est un peu de la
superstition si compte c'est aujourd'hui
demain donc aujourd'hui cette équipe je
la trouve très intéressante dans ce
cadre de 3-1 qui se présente qui va
peut-être se transformer en quatre trois
aujourd'hui ce qui est intéressant c'est
l'ambiance qu'il y a dans cette équipe
ce qui est intéressant c'est Mbappe qui
est attendu comme le got comme la
révélation une nouvelle fois à son
niveau de cette coupe du monde donc tout
est en place pour avoir une belle équipe
de France pour avoir un très joli
parcours maintenant il y a plus qu'à
regarder et surtout ne pas s'appuyer sur
les statistiques le passé histoire qui
parfois se trouve assez handicapant
alors pour les noms initiés 4 3 ça veut
dire quatre derrière trois milieux et 3
devant je dis ça on a décidé spécialiste
donc je veux me battais tout le monde
connaît donc ça va reposer sur lui voilà
évidemment alors c'est vrai que comme
disait Claude précédemment Claude Leroy
c'est vrai que Mbappe avait été quand
même le Factory X en 2018 là
nécessairement avec l'absence de benzeba
on n'est pas dans l'obligation de faire
le jeu on peut toujours miser sur la
vitesse et sur la contre-attaque c'est à
dire lancer vite Mbappé en attaque et on
sait que avec grâce à sa vitesse et à
cette technique il est tout à fait en
mesure d'effacer un ou plusieurs
défenseurs et de marquer il terrifie
tous les défenseurs
savoir qui doit charger Mbappé c'est
juste terrifiant déjà il dort mal la
nuit il dort pas de la nuit d'avant et
ensuite juste avant la rentrée
un cauchemar à charger c'est c'est un
enfer et aujourd'hui pour tous les
défenseurs quelle que soit le défenseur
et son niveau aujourd'hui on a affaire à
quelqu'un qui est hors norme Mbappe
c'est un joueur tel que peut les laisser
en son temps tels que Maradona l'été en
son temps tel que Platini que vous
connaissez très bien aussi il était en
son temps c'est à dire c'est un joueur
quand c'est pas comment prendre qu'on ne
sait pas comment attraper et il faut
qu'il soit dans un bon tempo s'il est
dans un manque et qu'il a l'équipe avec
lui et qu'il arrive à peine un chef
d'orchestre un caraïane à dirigé toute
cette équipe ça peut faire de très très
belles choses merci en tout cas un mot
de conclusion oui on croise les doigts
pour Mbappé et vive la France et vive le
foot français exactement
qui était avec nous il y a quelques
instants merci à yote Samuel qui est en
direct du Qatar Nina Masson également
merci Hanina donc qui était en direct
vous avez vu de ce bar où il y avait ses
fans qui attendent ce match qui va
démarrer dans 5 minutes exactement ce
match donc France Australie merci à vous
tous d'avoir suivi et restez sur France
[Musique]